hey my name is Samuel thank you so much
for checking this video out I'm gonna
give you in this video the overview of
what makes a good property investment so
if you're a property investor already
you buy houses for a living or if you're
thinking of buying a house you just got
to watch this video so these are the
three things that make a great property
investment please do smash that like
button down below don't forget to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already subscribed I really appreciate
that
so first things this if you're buying
gold silver you'll find stocks and
shares or dividends and in a company you
can't buy them below market value you
can't buy Bitcoin below market value you
can't negotiate to buy Bitcoin cheaper
the price is the price where is the
thing I love about property is you can
you can negotiate to buy it cheaper than
what it is before I tell you what makes
a good property investment let me tell
you what makes a bad one what not to buy
most people that lose money they buy off
plan so they'll buy a house before it's
been built often you're gonna get burned
doing that also they buy offshore so
they'll buy a house in a exotic area and
they're excited and they're buying it
with their feelings as opposed to their
formulas off plant offshore often lead
to no money for you and disappointment
so be careful of those things not saying
you can never make money just be careful
this is what you should not buy do not
buy a house as an investment because you
like the house because you think whom I
could live in there one day if it all
hits the fan at least think that this is
a back-up plan I don't buy a house for
that reason don't buy a house because
you think that you could maybe have
holidays there terrible plan terrible
terrible plan best way to lose money is
to buy a house as an investment and
think I'll go there for my holidays it's
just stupid you're just gonna lose money
seriously become a liability not an
asset no don't even try and kill two
birds ever don't buy a house and think
well it's near my son's university like
it doesn't matter what's a good
investment a good investment is a
property that makes you money that's it
if it makes you money it's an asset it's
a good investment if it doesn't make you
money if it loses you
no matter how pretty it is no matter how
many no matter how many pictures you can
take outside of it don't try and do it
for any other reason don't you make
money don't buy a house to try to help
people but I has to make money and then
with that money you can then help people
so what should you do then number one is
buy it below market value
discounted houses one of the reasons I
love property so much is because you can
buy them discounted when you know what
you're doing and you know how to
negotiate you know what to look for you
can buy a house twenty thirty percent
below market value and if you cannot do
that with Bitcoin you cannot do that
with gold and silver you cannot do that
with stocks and shares you just buy at
the price whereas in property you make
money when you buy as long as you know
to buy below market value
next buy for cash flow don't be obsessed
with anything else apart from cash flow
so you want to buy below market value
and you want to be getting positive cash
flow in your bank every month so here's
how to work out whether you're going to
be makin cash flow or not when you buy a
house work out what the expenses will be
the mortgage payments the utilities if
it's HMO the insurance why all the the
management costs what are all the
expenses then look at what the rent will
be then minus the expenses off of the
rent and you should be left with a nice
healthy profit at the end of the day so
a minimum of two hundred pounds a month
I mean honestly even if it's a fifty
grand house really cheap house where you
only put down ten grand
turn Japan a month minimum you know so
really typically you want to be making
500 pounds pause or on the house of
course it depends how much you put down
that's how you work out the return on
investment people talk about yields all
the time the yield it doesn't matter
what the yield is what matters is what
are you putting down and what are you
getting back and then you divide those
two together to work out the return on
investment what's my monthly profit
times that by twelve my annual profit
divide that by my total investment not
the total purchase price how much do
you personally put down divide them
together return-on-investment
I want to be seen a minimum of 15
percent return on investment 20 percent
and above and you do really well so make
sure you bite below market value make
sure that it's cashflow positive and
then thirdly is you want to buy and this
is almost like a cherry on the cake okay
don't let the don't let the tail wag the
dog but this is a big bonus is you want
to buy in an area where by you suspect
that the house is about to go up in
value and that's called capital
appreciation and how do you predict
capital appreciation well there's
there's it's quite complicated there's
patterns you can look at in the market
and in the economy I would suggest that
you come and join me at the property
investors crash course I'm gonna leave a
link below with tickets and you can come
for free ok free property investors
crash course two days so all about this
stuff
but a little thing I'll say is if the if
the property area is bottomed out when
it drops it will always follow an
expansion what most people think is oh
my gosh it's dropped it's gonna drop
more no after a recession will come an
expansion and after an expansion will
come a recession so you want to buy one
houses of below and property's a bottom
down you want to buy below market value
you want to buy for cash flow and that
that makes a good investment and then
what do you do when the house goes up in
value
do you sell it no you never sell you
only sell a house if the house stops
making you money but until then don't
sell it if it goes up and value what you
do is you refinance it so if you've what
has for a hundred grand and now it's
worth 150 about fifty thousand pounds if
you sell it that's your profit and you
pay tax on profit so you fifty that
suppose a good drop well is if you
refinance it and you pull that 50
thousand pounds out I you borrow against
it technically that's debt that you can
then reinvest into properties by the way
guess how much tax you pay
not nothing so what what would you sell
it you just refinance it and it goes up
again you refinance it and with that
when you refinance it with that money
you're going to buy another house you're
going to buy another house
snowballs success breeds success with
the cash flow that you make in you're
going to in you're going to reinvest
that in to buy more houses and until
you're a position whereby you're
financially free you should be buying
stupid stuff so first things first don't
worry about being debt-free become
financially free buy good property
investments and that's that's that's the
summary so to learn more come on the
property investors crash course I hope
that was helpful please do comment your
thoughts below in the comments and let
me know let me know below I want to know
let me know are you more excited about
capital appreciation or are you more
excited about cash flow cash flow drop
it in the comments capital appreciation
drop it in the comments I'm really
interested subscribe I'll see you next
video thank you so much for watching
[Music]